[Musique]
moi je m'occupe de la terre je m'occupe
de faire en sorte que la terre soit le
plus fertile possible
et après en gros je plante et puis je
m'occupe plus quasiment plus des plantes
il y a que si elles sont envahies par
trop de d'herbes sauvages qui les
étouffent que là je
rache les herbes sauvages pour pas
qu'elle soit étouffée si elle n'a pas
beaucoup je le fais je fais rien
[Musique]
tout ça ici
c'est tomates là elles ont jamais eu la
moindre goutte d'eau je les ai planté le
28 juin quand c'était déjà complètement
sec du coup il y a quasiment aucune
mauvaise herbe qui a poussé il y a en
fait j'ai mis juste un peu d'eau au pied
et après j'ai jamais arrosé et elles ont
quand même poussé alors que ici il y a
même pas 10 15 cm de terre c'est que des
dalles de rocher là comme ça
donc tout ce que la plante a apprend si
elle apprend à résister à 4 mois de
sécheresse ou à 6 mois de sang d'une
goutte d'eau et avec des canicules
pendant deux ou trois mois et qu'elle
survit
ses graines la génération suivante sont
déjà bien habitués à vivre sans eau
après quand on dit sans eau ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas d'eau du tout parce
que il faut quand même il y a toujours
de l'eau dans les rochers
les rochers sont tous plus ou moins pour
eux
[Musique]
cette année avec la canicule on s'est on
a bien vu que on pouvait réduire la
température à l'intérieur de la serre
par rapport à ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur et par une irrigation très
pointue c'est à dire un peu au goutte à
goutte par dessous pour alimenter la
plante avec cette huit irrigation de
quelques minutes par jour plus une
brumisation de quelques minutes là aussi
de midi jusqu'à 18h le soir on a réussi
à faire baisser sensiblement la
température et à maintenir un taux
d'hygrométrie qui ont permis à la plante
de se développer on est
[Musique]